les américains veulent retourner sur la
lune y mettre en orbite une station
spatiale habitée
le canada met le cap sur la lune un
projet sans précédent auxquels le canada
a accepté de participer le gouvernement
du canada investira 2.0 5 milliards de
dollars sur 24 ans dans notre programme
spatial et le projet du gateway et
lunaire le projet nommé gateway ou
passerelle lunaire sera situé mille fois
plus loin de la terre que la station
spatiale internationale dans laquelle
séjourne actuellement l'astronaute david
saint jacques
l'espace est un défi immense qui exige
de travailler ensemble et comme le veut
la tradition un bras canadien sera
installé sur la future station notre
savoir faire dans le domaine de la
robotique est devenu une composante
essentielle des missions spatiales
en plus de la robotique le canada compte
mettre de l'avant son expertise en
intelligence artificielle le futur bras
canadien devra accomplir des missions de
façon autonome
parce que la station lunaire ne sera pas
habiter en permanence et sera beaucoup
trop loin pour permettre un contrôle à
distance
cette nouvelle stratégie spatiale nous
permettra non seulement d'assurer
l'avenir de notre programme
d'astronautes ainsi que la force de
l'industrie aérospatiale mais aussi de
créer des emplois pour les canadiens
d'encourager l'innovation et d'ouvrir la
voie à de nouvelles découvertes
scientifiques
cette mission vers la lune a pour but
d'apprendre à vivre loin très loin de la
terre est préparée l'humain à une
éventuelle mission sur mars faut
apprendre à vivre en autonomie presque
complète à grande distance de la terre
pour préparer un voyage qui sera d'une
durée de plusieurs années vers la
planète mars
la nasa compte aussi installer de future
base directement sur la lune pour à
terme établir une colonie autour et sur
la lune ya évidemment
des intérêts commerciaux qu'on pourrait
imaginer l'exploitation des ressources
même sur la lune en acceptant d'appuyer
les ambitions lunaires de la nasa
le canada s'assure aussi une place dans
le futur de l'exploration spatiale
je suis bien sûr extrêmement content
pour mes collègues astronautes canadiens
jamie jones et josh et aussi pour les
scientifiques les ingénieurs les
travailleurs spécialisés du secteur
spatial canadien
la nasa prévoit lancer un premier module
autour de la lune dans seulement trois
ans et faire les premières expériences
scientifiques des 2026 ici vincent
maisonneuve radio canada montréal